when you walk into your neighborhood
public library you expect the librarian
to help you find your next favorite book
or some accurate information on a topic
interest you don't probably expect the
librarian to come running out from
behind the reference desk with narcan
ready to revive someone overdosing on
heroin or fentanyl but this is happening
at some libraries public libraries have
always been about community support with
all kinds of services and programs from
assisting with job seeking efforts to
locating resources for voter rights to
providing free meals to kids and teens
even but what we think of as community
support takes on new urgency when you're
in the middle of an opioid and overdose
crisis I work at the McPherson square
library of the Free Library of
Philadelphia it's located in Kensington
one of the lowest income communities in
Philadelphia with a long history of
being isolated from resources and
opportunity and because of that it has
been the center to the city's drug trade
and drug use for decades and so inside
the neighborhood our library is nestled
inside of a park which has unfortunately
garnered a reputation for being a place
to find and use drugs especially heroin
out in the open
putting us and the community in direct
contact with the drug trade and use on a
daily basis and so inside the library it
is routine to see people visibly
intoxicated on opioids eyes closing body
swaying slowly it is routine for me to
ask them if they are okay but at the
same time remind them if they can't keep
their eyes open they have to go it is
routine for our volunteer Teddy to pick
up dozens of discarded needles on our
property and throughout the park and it
is normal for kids to come into the
library to tell me or our guard sterling
that's
someone is outside using which typically
means finding someone injecting on our
front steps benches or near the building
then asking them to move along because
kids see them and it is normal for the
community to see people in various
states of intoxication and withdrawal to
see people buying and selling and to see
people act and react violently I'm not
sharing this to sensationalize
Kensington I'm sharing this because this
is the reality of a community that is
constantly striving to move forward but
due to factors like structural racism
urban segregation the cyclical nature of
poverty of trauma
the community has inequitable access to
education health care employment and
more and this is also what it's like
when the drug trade and use affects
every aspect of life in the neighborhood
and the opioid epidemic has only
amplified that stress when I was hired
by the Free Library in 2013 I
specifically chose to work at McPherson
because I understand what it's like to
grow up in an environment where
substance use disorder shaped the
everyday and I wanted to use those
personal experiences as a guide for my
work but before I get to that I want to
share what it was like to witness this
epidemic grow in Kensington like many
other communities we were just not
prepared we began to take notice of IDs
we were saying addresses from nearby in
upstate counties and then slowly out of
state once people from Arkansas Ohio
South Carolina Alabama coming to
Philadelphia for cheap heroin people
began to linger longer and longer in our
public restroom causing us to pay more
attention to the restroom than to our
daily responsibilities because it was an
accessible place to use drugs just
purchased one day our toilet clogged so
badly in the restroom we were forced to
close our library for two days because
the culprit of the clog was discarded
needles for a while prior to that
incident we had been asking for a sharps
container
the restaurant and after that the
library administration quickly approved
installing one along with hiring
bathroom monitors and as the weather
warmed we struggled to respond
people began camping out in the park for
days weeks you could walk outside on a
sunny warm day to find multiple groups
of people in various states of
intoxication and children playing in
between them the amount of needles
collected by Teddy on a monthly basis
skyrocketed from one hundred to three
hundred to five hundred to eight hundred
to over a thousand with many found on
our front steps and the playground then
there were the overdoses so many
occurred outside in the park some inside
the library Stirling our guard would
spend his time walking in and out of the
building and throughout the park
constantly making sure everyone was safe
because at times our fear of having
someone overdosed and died came close
one overdose in particular occurred
after school so the library was full of
kids noise and commotion
and in all of that we heard the thud
from inside the public restroom when we
opened the door we found a man on the
floor and responsive he was pulled out
in plain sight of everyone kids teens
adults families someone on staff called
911 someone else escorted the kids and
teens downstairs somebody want to flag
down the ambulance in the park and the
rest of us we just waited this had
become our overdose drill because at the
time it was all we could do so we waited
and we watched this man lose air seize
up he was dying I don't know how many of
you have witnessed an overdose on
opioids but it's horrific because you
know the gasping for air the loss of
color in someone's face is a timer
running down on the chances of this
person surviving but luckily for this
man the ambulance arrived and he
received a dose of naloxone through
gen-i reread jolted like he was
electrocuted and he pulled the needle
out and he told the paramedics to back
off and then he stood up and he walked
out and we we went back to work because
people were still asking for time on the
computers kids still needed help with
their homework and this was our job our
purpose I think that incident stays with
me because of the waiting it made me
feel helpless and it was that feeling of
helplessness that reminded me so all of
my childhood before I was born both of
my parents began using heroin it made
our lives chaotic and unstable promises
being made and constantly broken they're
fighting the weight of their secret the
weight of our secret kept so much so
called normal out of our lives every
time we'd be dropped off at our
grandparents house I'd be stuck on the
thought that I was never going to see
them again
every time we'd be left in a car at a
house at a store I cry and every time I
saw those El tracks the same ones I take
to work now it's mcpherson from the
backseat of a car I'd be angry because
even kids know when their parents are
trying to score drugs there was so
little I could do to control what was
going on around me that that feeling of
helplessness was overwhelming I
struggled in school struggled to read I
was prone to anger and depression when I
was 11 years old I started smoking which
shortly after let's my own experiences
with drugs and alcohol I convinced
myself that my parents past would be my
future but eventually both of my parents
entered recovery and maintained recovery
from opioid use and their strength and
their commitment provided support and
Steve ability for me and my siblings and
it was those personal experiences that
brought me to McPherson choosing to be a
librarian and choosing to be at
McPherson was me letting go of that
feeling of helplessness and finding ways
to be supportive to others and one way
to provide support was learning how to
admit
nor can Public Library's respond to the
needs of their communities and not
knowing how to utilize narcan was a
disservice to the needs of our community
we were on the front lines and
desperately needed access to this
life-saving tool so finally in late
February of 2017 after much advocating
we finally received training from
prevention point Philadelphia and about
a month or so later I utilized an arcane
for the first time to save someone's
life it was after school again and Teddy
came into the library and said someone
was overdosing on a front bench someone
on staff called 9-1-1 again and I
grabbed the narcan kit the woman was
barely in her 20s and barely breathing
her friend was frantically slapping her
in the face and hopes of reviving her I
administered the narcan nasally and
thankfully she came to but before the
ambulance arrived she and her friend ran
off and when I finally turned around I
saw the kids it's that common to the
library on a daily basis some that I
have known for years standing on the
steps of the building they saw
everything and it didn't seem like they
were visibly upset or in shock
and so I walked into the building right
into our work room and I cried I cried
partly from the shock of what just
happened because I never thought I'd be
saving anybody's life ever but I mostly
cried because of the kids this is their
normal this is the community's normal
this is a catastrophic normal and in
that moment I was forced to confront
once again that this should never be
normal and as with my childhood when
you're in it you just accept it the
opioid epidemic is not just about those
living with opiate use disorder because
the reach of the epidemic goes well
beyond those living with this and their
families it impacts the entire community
Kensington was a community and crisis
before this for reasons that are endemic
and intertwined and anyone familiar with
the neighborhood can think of why racial
disparities failure of local and federal
government to properly fund schools
lack of Economic Opportunity and what
we're trying to do at McPherson is find
ways to support this community out of
crisis and perhaps now because of the
epidemic more people are paying
attention to Kensington but regardless
of that at McPherson we will continue to
do what we can with the resources we
have and we will continue to provide
whatever help we can in hopes of keeping
our community safe and healthy because
public libraries have always been more
than just books we are a physical
shelter a classroom a safe haven a
lunchroom a resource hub and yes even a
lifeline thank you
[Applause]